the Cato Institute recently held a
conference in Washington DC on ending
the global drug war recent TV spoke with
a number of the featured speakers which
included former drug warriors
politicians intellectuals and
journalists from across the political
spectrum my Damascus moment if you will
was when a very good friend of mine was
who was an undercover narcotics agent
was brutally murdered on the streets
here in Washington DC my personal
experiences are enforcing the drug laws
then becoming a coroner where my role
changed from enforcement to prevention
to keep people alive and so I watched as
it escalated up into the 90s because I
am a Colombian and I have seen
everything about it the added value of
drugs is produced by prohibition and
with that other value you can corrupt
everything and you stimulate a level of
violence and cruelty them unknown to
this day oh it's horrendous it has
created an enormous organized crime
network throughout the region that is
much more powerful than any of the frail
young democracies and most of these
countries have very weak institutions
such as Mexico and Central America you
have corrupt courts corrupt police
forces and the war on drugs is like
aggravating these these weak
institutions you make pressure here
because there meanwhile the demand
continues to be the same and it's not
fair that Latin Americans have to bear
the burden in order to prevent Americans
from consuming a substance that they
want there's actually a great deal of
resentment toward the United States and
be part because it's the United States
that really applies pressure to prevent
other approaches from being taken they
insist that everything remain
criminalized there are treaties that
they insist upon enforcing with respect
to smaller countries that bar them from
with different approaches you know
because he's a man of the left I think
he has more of a burden to show that he
does not embrace the drug culture that's
why I think that if we're gonna have
change in the marijuana laws it's gonna
have to come to them
from the right in the same way that you
know Nixon went to China so here's a guy
who probably got the votes of 95% of all
weed smokers in the country I'm against
it I guess it's my straightforward
answers of course I'm against it but it
is ironic in a way that pleases me I'm
not a big proponent of decriminalization
I think that in order to reduce the
violence we need to make the growth
manufacture and distribution legitimate
as well as the usage everybody wants to
call it legalization I say simply
controlling it much as we control
alcohol and tobacco and British Columbia
it's it's estimated it's an eight
billion dollar a year business that's in
one province if I control that I get two
billion dollars in taxes which I could
then put to healthcare there are seven
amazing members of the United States
Congress right now who have created a
piece of legislation I think it's called
the repeal marijuana prohibition Act of
2011 I don't think there is a newspaper
or a magazine in the United States that
has endorsed what seven members of
Congress have endorsed so I haven't
heard from any drug warrior or any
person who believes in prohibition a
very convincing argument about how do
they intend to win the war on drugs was
it like to eradicate completely a drug
consumption that's never happen in
history
I think there's absolutely zero chance
that it can be won I agree with the
global Commission on drugs which
concluded that the global war on drugs
has failed and I found that formulation
interesting because it doesn't say it is
failing or is likely to fail but has
failed human
being do drugs since ancient ancient
days I'm 63
I grew up in the 60s you know it's been
going on since then I mean if it was a
gateway drug every person virtually
everybody I know would be a junkie relax
take it easy tolerate me you just can
never win it and you're causing a lot of
heartbreak you're causing a lot of agony
after the war on drugs everything is hit
the fan start by taking marijuana off
Schedule one that's just stupid
you must direct the administrator of the
DEA to sit down with the states that
have medical marijuana laws in order to
change the regulations regarding medical
marijuana so state laws can be
rationalized I think that the war on
drugs is so glaringly stupid and
counterproductive that I don't believe
that people in in in policymaking
positions are unaware of it I think we
just lack political courage to argue
against it I don't think that
constructive change on this issue will
come from Washington in Washington has
never leads on anything that's important
I think it generally happens from civil
society and from the grassroots and from
the local areas look at the other drugs
and figure out a way to phase in a
legalization and regulatory model that
causes less harm death and destruction
than prohibition you can point to other
parts of the world now where there are
liberalized policies and none of these
parade of Horrible's that we've been
told forever will happen are actually
happening it's a huge waste of money a
huge waste of humanity to imprison these
people by the hundreds of thousands in
exchange for almost no benefit and and
it's this policy of prohibition that's
causing the violence and empowering the
cartels
you